listen women in music this has been an
incredible year for you and all women in
music but what does it mean to be here
tonight and be receiving this award you
really are changing the game thank you
well tonight is very special I feel like
now I'm 30 I feel like I'm more
connected to my like my feminine self
more than ever and I'm always surrounded
by a bunch of dudes like I'm fun being
wanted to do is that it took me a while
I feel like to connect with that part of
myself for some reason even though I'm
such a girly girl but I feel like I'm
just really proud of where the modern
the state of the modern woman it's like
where women are ahead is what you know
this year I feel like was a huge
explosion for so many things you know
women's mind bodies like creativity and
it's only gonna get better from here
we're loud and it's just it's it's just
really cool to see it's cool I think
it's a cool time to be alive and I think
art is reflecting that and I'm all for
it I'm all for supporting other women
you know you're receiving the innovator
award just a few weeks ago album of the
year and tomorrow the Grammy nominations
go out listen you got a set of Grammys
there's no pressure on you to get that
Grammy but what would it mean tomorrow
to get a nomination for this album that
isn't just incredible yeah well the
Grammys are a little bit different than
any other awards show because they're
it's more broad you know it's all genres
combined it's you know and there was so
much good music released today men and
women I just feel like you know the ante
is up like the social and political
landscape is a little chaotic and I
think out of that comes really brilliant
art and music and movies
and I just think that everyone just
really ever there's a lot of competitors
there's a lot of really great stuff out
there so to be even you know maybe in
the running or something it's just a big
honor
I created because I love to create and I
create because it makes me feel good
obviously the rest is icing on the cake
but to someone who really doesn't get a
lot of radio play to be you know on a
lot of best of list and getting some
attention from outside of the genre that
I came from is special because it means
that to me that people connect with my
lyrics and that's a whole the hard words
that I've been doing this year has been
paying off you know so we'll see what
happens I'm happy either way I just I'm
just thankful to be able to do what I
love and I'm really thankful that I got
to put out this album and I'm glad to be
here tonight so yeah off to it and I'm
thankful because I'm bopping tell me
about the fashion tonight you always
bring any look incredible it looks
vintage well it's actually not it's
really exciting because I'm wearing for
the first time Brandon Maxwell and I
love his stuff but also I love it even
more because he is from Longview Texas
which is down the road for me hi I'm an
East Texas girl like y'all long view is
so country and I'm from golden which is
like outside in Mineola which is outside
us in between Thailand Longview well
he's from Longview and so it's really
cool to see a fellow he's Texan we grew
up with no high-fashion like anywhere
near know and it's just cool to see
somebody just fall in their you know
their inspiration and doing it for
themselves and making a big name for
themselves so I am very proud to wear
Brandon Maxwell tonight and I'm feeling
like I'm bringing my like Miranda like
brunette Miranda Priestly
a little bit that's kind of like you
know that was in my mind
New York honey you got a badass and a
pair of pumps I need honey to prepaid
Ariana is also being honored tonight
what does she meant to you as like a
fellow woman sort of you know in the
music business I mean there's I love
that tonight is all about its diverse
it's very diverse
so like Ariana says I'm a huge fan of
her record you know like it just
reinforces the fact that we are all in
this together
doesn't matter what genre we come from
we are all creative women we all deserve
to be heard we all deserve a fair shot
and I just think that tonight is about
like letting loose there's also a lot of
women behind the scenes that make it
possible for us to you know to be able
to do this and be here so yeah
[Music]